死とは 仏教において大変 大事な言葉なんです
他の宗教にしても
死ということは 中心的な思考なんですよ
で なんで人間が 宗教というものを考え出したかというと
人が死んじゃうからなんですね
人はどんどん死んでいっちゃうし
それで なんで死ぬことが 宗教になってしまったんでしょうかね
それは 仏教以前
仏教以前からもね
他の宗教というものは ございましたから
そういう人々がなんで そういうこと（を考えたのか）
死は宗教の
まあ なんて言いますかね
ファウンデーション
あるいは土台
宗教は死という概念から 発生しているものなんですね
なんで死ぬということを 宗教にしたんでしょうか
昔の人々だったらね
たいていは獲物を捕って 食べて生活していました
原始的な人々が
生きたままで
鹿やら牛やらを食べられませんね
ですから死んだか 死んでいないかと（意識された）
だから死ぬことというのは
死体ということは
自分の餌だと思った方が
もっと具体的な 考え方になるのでした
なるはずでした
魚を取っても
生きているままでは食べませんし
食べられませんし
それはなんとか死んでから 死体を焼いたりして食べていました
動物なんかが死ぬということは よく見ていたんだけど
（ところが）人間が死んだ場合は
なんか違うことを 考えちゃったんですね
それはどういうことかというと
やっぱり牛やら鹿やらね
死んでもらった方が 美味しいものを食べられるんだけど
なんか自分の 周りの人々が死んでいくと
それは嫌だと思ったんです
それは嫌だと
自分にとって 嫌なことが起きてるんですね
好ましくないことが 起きてるんです
それを何とかしなくちゃいけないと 考えていたところで
いろいろ宗教的な 概念が生まれてきたんですよ
人間っていうのは
まあ動物は置いといて
人間は人間が死ぬのは嫌ですかと
人間が他の人間が死ぬことを 嫌だと思ってますかと
（実は）そうじゃないんです
他の人だったら 死んだ方がいいと思ってるんです
自分の周りの人々は 死んでほしくない
他の人だったら死んでしまえと
関係ないんだと
と思ってるんですよ 普通は
ですから 原始時代でも
それからどんどんね
人間にも結構 歴史がありますから
昔は平気で隣の村に 村ではなくてね
原始時代のこというと
ちょっと山を森を通って どこかへ行ったら
他の人間に出会ったら
その人々と戦って
その人々を殺したりする
アフリカでしたか
首狩り部族も 最近まで生きていたんだから
人間を見たら捕まえて 殺して食べる人々もいました
それは少ないし
おそらくおいしくなかったでしょうね
で 食べる人は少なかったんだけど
首を取って
いろいろと加工して 小さくして
腰に巻いて持っていく
首にかけて
どうだい
俺がヒーローではないかっていう感じで
威張っている
それはもう 関係ない人だったら死んでしまえ ということなんですね
それはもう 原始時代のことでね
我々はそんなね
悪いこと
みっともないことしませんね と思ってるんだけど
これは大違いで
今 考えているのは
どうすれば1億人 2億人でも いっぺんに殺せるか
ということを 今 考えているんですよ
今の人間の考え方は
どうすれば自分が 完全安全状態にいて
他人は 完璧に全面的に破壊できるかと
例えば 地球の中で なんか穴でも掘って
洞窟でも掘って 隠れていても
爆発しなくても 殺せる方法はないかと
超音波やら いろんな電波やら いろんな放射能やら
もう何でも使って
たとえ隠れていても 殺せる方法ないかとかね
それから最近 と言っても
この４０年の間で作った武器の中（でいうと）
例えば人々が 森の中に隠れていると
もう見えないんですね
飛行機から
でも 見える眼鏡があるんですよ
人間っていうのは 体があったかいんだから
木よりは 温度が高いんですよ
動物の体の温度は また少々違います
例えば 猫だったら人間よりは体温が高いし
象なんかは少々 低いだろうと思います
人間の体温は知ってるんですよ
そこで その温度で どれぐらい温度があるかと
これで映像で映っちゃうんですね
そこで 簡単に動物と人間の区別ができます
動物は４本の足で歩くんだから
温度の映像が横になってるんですね
人間っていうのは バカだから立って歩くでしょう
森の中でも
そうすると 縦線の映像が映っちゃうんですね
あっ これ人間だと
もし熊でもね
何か木で ハチミツでも食べようかなと 立ってたところで
間違って 熊でも 人間だと間違う可能性あります
あまり間違わないんですよ
もう熊の体の構造違いますから
足が短いんだから
人間より
ですから
森の中に隠れていても
もう夜でも見える
今の戦争っていうのは
飛行船の先端技術で 爆弾を落とす場合は すべて夜なんです
だから 普通の街に生活している人と 村に生活する人々には
どうにもできない状態で
技術とか何も持ってないんだから
夜は暗いんだから 寝るしか方法ないんですね
その時 真っ暗闇で 飛行機が明確に全部見て
で 爆弾を落とすというふうに 技術開発していて
大変 素晴らしい世界です
人間っていうのは 昔から あまり考え方は変わってないんですよ
自分の身内が死んでほしくない
他の人間は もう死んでしまえと
という考え方なんですね
それでも 宗教はどこから始めたかというと
私の身内の人々は死んでほしくない という
考え方から 発生しているんですよ
皆様 あまり賛成したくないと思いますけど
私も あまり言いたくないんだけど
やっぱり 事実はそういう事実なんですね
マスコミみたいに あったものは
もう何といいますか
変えて みんなの気持ちをよくするような
ストーリーは 私は言いたくないんです
ただ 事実をそのまま言いたい
事実はあまり面白くないんです
ですから
自分の親が死んでほしくない
自分の子供が死んでほしくない
自分と一緒に仲良くしている 知り合いの人々が
一緒にいる人々が 死んでほしくない
だから神様にお祈りしましょう という概念なんですよ
それは美化して
とことん美化して
死に対するすごいことを 私は喋るべきか（そうでは）ないか
との疑問が
私にも一応あります
とりあえず そんなことだとまずわかってほしい
人間っていうのは
死ぬのは嫌がりますけど
本当のところはどういうことかと
他人の死は もう何のこともない
何の気持ちも 何のこともなく
もう冷静に認める
死んだ方がいいと思う
他人が死ぬ場面なんか見て 喜びまで感じる
やれやれと
エールまで送ったりする
でも 自分の身内の場合になると
また態度が違いますね
なぜそんなことを言ったかというと
あまり宗教の世界で 死に関して言ってることっていうのは
あの程度のことだから
あまりそれも そんなに真剣に考えなくてもいい ということなんですよ
なぜかというと 聖書にも一行あるんですよ
イエスが言うんですね
私は ユダヤ人を救うために来たんだと
自分の民族だけのことなんですね
他人はどうなってもいい というふうに思っているんですよ
日本で 仏教だと大変思って 尊敬している
インドのヒンドゥー教
人類のために語っているんじゃないんですよ
あれは バラモン人たちだけの教えなんですよ
こちらでいくら護摩焚いたり いろいろやったりしたって
もうカースト違いますから
おそらく 天国に行かないかもしれません
あれは バラモン人が天国に行くために作った教えなんです
ですから
宗教の話を聞いて
ちょっと少々聞いてみてください
聞いてみると
自分の仲間が 天国に行く話なんですよ
人類が天国に行く話は 言ってないんです
とにかく お釈迦様が言うのは
我々に
伝統的に みんなが言ってる考え方っていうのは
そのまま はい 正しい
はい 正しい と言うんじゃなくて
新しい視点というか
新しい角度で
もっと客観的な角度で 物事を見た方がいいんです
何でも 素晴らしい
古いものだったら 何でも素晴らしいと
言いたがる気持ちは わからないわけでもないんだけど
これはもう ずっとみんながやってるんだからやってることで
古いものだったら 素晴らしいものだ とかね
古い人々の思考だったら 素晴らしい思考だ とかね
そういうふうに 勝手に言うんだけど
ちょっと見たらね
それほどのことでもない可能性もあるし
それなりに素晴らしい思考である場合もあるし
とにかく 死に対しては
人間は こういう考え方を持ってるんですね
私の身内の人々が死ぬのは嫌ですと
そのところは理解できます
身内の人々が死んじゃったら
自分が損するんですよ
自分がすごく楽しく遊んでいる
自分の子供が あっちこっち走り回って
ものすごく
なんていうか にぎやかで うるさくて 遊んでいる
子供が突然 熱でも出して 倒れて死んじゃったら
なんか すごく悲しくなる
自分が損しちゃうんですね
自分の奥さんでも 死んでしまったら
子供を残して
これ 大変なことなんですよ
だから 嫌だと思っちゃうんですね
奥さんにしても
食べ物を持ってくる男が 突然 死んでしまったら
自分がどのように 子供を食べさせるかと
問題が出てくるんだから
だから 身内の人々が死ぬのは嫌 ということになるんです
それ 私がね
いつでも失礼なことを言うんだからね
嘘を言っていると思ってるでしょ
この坊主は 何か変なことばかり言ってるんだから
これも 大した根拠はないんだ と思ってるんですけど
我々も たとえ親戚であろうとも
ものすごい嫌な人がいて
例えば 財産に対して裁判かけるわ
喧嘩するわ
いろんな ひどいことをするわと
そうやって 自分のものすごい嫌な わがままで嫌な親戚がいて
死んじゃったりする
その時 悲しみますかね
あ やっと死んだか と思いますね
その時は
だから 身内の人でも
自分にとって すごく嫌な人だったら
そういうのも 時々ありますからね
例えば 兄弟同士でも 兄弟だから仲良くするということも
いつでもあるわけじゃないんですね
兄弟っていうのは ほとんどは仲良くしていますけど
たまに ものすごく嫌な人も 兄弟として生まれてくるんだから
どうしようもないんですよ
そこでも 一番 普通なのは
例えば 兄弟二人
三人がいる
で わがままっていうのは
長男とかね
かなり わがままだからね
それで 親の面倒を何も見ないで
平気で家を出て
自分勝手に生活する
でも 親にしたら やっぱり長男だから
かなり可愛いんですよ
それでも 親をいくら裏切っても
親にいくら邪魔をしても
どこかで 人の面倒を見てあげたりするということは
親は 親としてもうやってしまうんですね
それで 親が病気になって倒れて
1年 10年とかね
15年ぐらいでも
病気で ずっと看病しなくちゃいけなくなったところで
次男か もう次の長女か 誰か
3番目の人とか
まあ性別やめましょう
一応 1番目の子供がそうなったら
2番目か 3番目の子が 一生懸命 親の面倒を見たりする
それで お見舞いにでも来てください と頼んでも
もう来てこない
来ない で
兄弟も あまり仲が良くないんだから
兄弟同士でも喧嘩したりもする
そこで 3番目の人が あるいは
2番目の人が 一生懸命親のことを見て
上の人がどうでもいい ということで面倒を見る
そういう人が 親が死んだ時だけ すぐ来るんです
死んでから
来て いきなり 葬式どうですか？
ではなくて
この家は俺のものだと
俺が長男だから
今まで親の面倒を見た人々を追い出しちゃって
全部 財産を自分のものにしようとする ということは
ないわけじゃないんですよ
そういう話
私はあまり 日本の皆様のことを知りませんけど
私さえも ちゃんと本人から 具体的に聞いたことがあります
死んでから 財産 自分のものだと
そこまでは知りません　親は
そういうふうな家族も 時々 出てきますし
それで 身内の人は みんな死ぬのは 楽しいか
嫌 ということでもないんですよ
本当にものすごい嫌な
すごい迷惑する人だったら
たとえ 兄弟であろうとも
たとえ 親であろうとも
死んだ方がいい と思う時もあります
その時も 全然
やっぱり 法事 やらなくちゃいけないとか
お墓参りしなくちゃ
そういう気持ちもないんですよ
死んでから
できれば 忘れちゃいますね
周りが何か文句を言うんだったら
自分の社会的な立場を守るために やってあげるぐらいのことで
ですから
人間 本当に 死ということを考えているんですかと
それぐらいの見方で みんな死について語る
ターミナルケアについても語る
ホスピスについても語る
ホスピス制度とかね
老人問題
どうしましょうかと語る
でも 見てください
誰一人 真面目じゃないでしょ
できれば やりたくない ってことでしょ
できれば やりたくない
例えば 日本は この老人
老人問題というかね
これから たくさん老人が出てくるんだと
これは 大変な迷惑 という角度で 国会で議論しているんです
大変な迷惑だと
それは 口では言わない
もし 私が間違っていたら直してください
私は あまり日本語を理解できるというところではないんだけど
一応 国会の議論とかは 聞いてはいます
勉強になりますから
勉強になりますよ
ですから 聞いてはいるんだけど
あれ 本当かと
本当にやりたくて
どうやればいいか ということを考えているか
これは 考えているのはもう お金がなくなっちゃうんだと
損するんだと
損する でもまあ迷惑ですね
この年取った連中は 一遍に死んでくれればいいんだけど
死んでもくれませんし
そんなこと言ったら 自分が次の選挙で負けちゃうし
しょうがない
なんとかしよう というぐらいのことで 考えたりはします
だから はっきりした答えが出てこない
はっきりした
年取ってから
老後 死ぬまで 安心して 幸せで楽しく
最後の人生をね
生きる この覚悟というかね
そういうものは 全然 出てこない
例えば 日本の方々には
日本で生まれてよかったと
年取って何もできなくなっても
結構 楽しく生きていられるんだと
社会がね
ちゃんと守ってくれるんだと
そういうシステムっていうのは 一向に出てこないでしょ
老後は心配ないと
ですから
私が言いたがっているのは
人間っていうのは
死に対してのアプローチは すごい
それほど美しいものではない ということなんですね
それほど 心を広く見ているわけじゃないんです
他人だったら
関係ないし
死んだ方がいいと
他人は負けた方がいいと
自分は負けたくはないんだと
自分の身内は死んでほしくないと
それでも 嫌な人は死んだ方がいいと
身内の中でも
その立場で 身内の人が死ぬ
あ これ大変だ
どうしましょうか
神様は助けてくれませんか と聞くでしょ
助けてくれますかね
神様がいてもね
そんな調子だったら
まあ
そこをまず理解して
ですから
仏教も結局 死ということは
ものすごく大事なポイントとして 扱っているんです
これは 考え直さなくてはならないんだと
もっと 目を覚ませなくてはならないんだと
なぜかというと
私たちが 今日のテーマ
話のポイントは
嫌という言葉
たった一言なんです
いや 嫌です
嫌いです
たった それだけですから
話がいくら伸びても
その一言だけ 覚えておいてください
そうすると全部 今日の話の内容はわかります
その嫌という一言を中心にして
この話は回しているだけ
そこで 死に対して 私はなぜ 私たちが なぜ
いろんなことを考えるかというと
身内の人々が死ぬのは嫌
プラス 私も死ぬのは嫌と
この 私も死ぬのが嫌です ということが 推測なんです
身内の人々が死ぬことは 見えているんだから
それは実感なんですね
自分の死は 単なる推測で
で 嫌と考える
そこで 嫌と考えるのはいいんだけど
そこで人間 もう一つやっちゃうんですよ
死ぬんだっていうことは 嫌なことだから 認めないんですね
認めない
それで 頭の中で明確に ある一つの命令というか
コマンドというか
ある一つの
言葉が 刷り込まれているんですよ
それは 私が死にません という言葉なんです
私が死にません
自分の心
自分の気持ち
ちょっといじってみてください
そこに基本的にあるのは 私が死にませんという 決まりなんです
証拠を
出そうとすれば いくらでも出せますよ
我々にとっては
私が死にません
生きているんだ ということから
エネルギーでやるというか
生きる勇気というか
頑張る気持ちというか
すべて 私が死にません だからやっているんですよ
生きているんだから
バカでかい建物
家作らなくちゃいけない
生きているんだから
バカ高い車 買わなくちゃいけない
もっと美しくならなくちゃいけないんだと
生きているんだから
もっと体重を減らして スマートにならなくちゃいけないんだと
自分が生きているんだから
敵を倒さなくちゃいけないんだと
だから 人々はいろんな 金が儲かる
いろんなものを集めるでしょう
人間っていうのは
いろんなものを集める
集める　集める
ちょっと量は知らない
動物もいますよ
集める動物は
ミツバチやらアリやら
葉っぱなんか取ってきて 集めるアリがいるでしょ
葉っぱを持っていて
自分のアリ塚の中に置いておいて
その上で カビが出てくるんですね
そのカビを食べて 生活しているんですよ
ちゃんと畑を作っているんです
カビといっても
人間でいえば しいたけみたいなもんなんですね
自分たちで しいたけではないんだけど
小さなマッシュルームの種類みたいな カビなんですけど
しいたけもカビの一種だからね
それを自分で作って
食べている
でも アリたちも あまりよく考えない場合はね
葉っぱなんか取りすぎとかあったら 中で栽培できなくなっちゃうし
とにかくそれぐらいのことを 動物もやってはいることはやってますけど
でもそういうのは 社会問題になったことはないんですね
あのアリたちに葉っぱ取られて
森が大変な危機になったとかね
はないんです
あるいは アリ塚の中で葉っぱがたまりすぎて
土がおかしくなったとかね
地面が柔らかくなったとかいうふうな 社会問題にはなってないんです
でも 人間がものを集める
集める
それはもう 社会問題
地球問題にまで 発展しているんですね
きりがなく集める
なぜ集めるかというと
自分たちが 永遠に生きているからなんです
だから
時々人々が昔
お城とか作ったりしたでしょ
イギリスなんかのお城やらね
ヨーロッパのお城なんかは
もう今 300年とか 400年のお城とかありますよ
400年前に作ったお城なんですけど
いまだに生活できる
ものすごい豪華で
いろんな人が作った宮殿とかあるでしょう
フランスでもね
有名な 驚くほどの 有名ななんとかね
ヴェルサイユですか
そういう宮殿とかあるでしょう
あれは これからも何年
何百年でも持てるでしょ
でも 作った人が あれで何十年住んでいたんですかね
自分の命は短くて
もうすぐ殺されますよと 知っていたならば
あるいは 自分がせいぜい5年だよと 思ったならば
あんなものは 作らないはずなんですよ
私は永遠なりと 死にませんという気持ち
確実に心の中にある
私は死にませんと
そいつは死んでもね
私は死にません
その考え方で生きているんですよ
だから そこをごまかしてはいけません
いつでもごまかしちゃう
たまに口先だけで
せいぜい私は あと20年でしょうとかね
自分の家系はほとんど短命だからね
私もそんなに長生きできるわけない
あんな嘘ですよ　あれは
あれは真面目に言っているわけじゃないんです
それは嘘
私は死にませんという
この土台があって
心の中に 作られた主観があって
その上で 人生設計しているんです
だから人生設計っていうのは
すべて できるだけ長持ちできるようにと 作っちゃうんですね
すべて自分のものにしたくなる
だから 他の人の生き方っていうのは 迷惑になるんですよ
他の人々も同じことをやると
かなり迷惑なんですね
で トラブルになったりもします
我々は というのは
人類みんな
私が死にません という立場で生きています
なぜ死にません という立場を作ったかというと
死ぬのは嫌ということがありますね
私が死ぬのは嫌ですと
私が死ぬのは嫌でした ということは実感かというと
そうでもありません
それは 身内の人々が死んだところで
悲しみ 苦しみを味わったんですね
で そこからなんとか推測して
ちょっとした推測なんですね
だったら 私も死ぬかもしれません ということは
その推測の上で 私は死にませんと まるっきり違う
嫌でない考え方を作る
死ぬのは嫌だったら 死にませんという言葉ほどありがたい
気持ちいい
賛成できる言葉が この世の中でないんですよ
だから 永遠な命を与えますよ と言えば
どんな人も騙すことはできるんです
何でもします
永遠な命
そういうことだから
いろいろな宗教の宣伝文句
少々考えてみてください
みんな何を約束するかというと
永遠な命 というものを約束するんですね
なぜかというと
あれほど
気持ちいい言葉がないんですよ
あれほど耳が喜ぶ言葉がないんですね
ですから
宗教は死ということを 真面目に考えていないんです
宗教が答えているのは
私が死にませんという 馬鹿げたことを考えている人々の 機嫌を取っているだけなんです
私は死にませんということは
どう見ても事実ではありませんでしょう
経験したことがないかもしれませんけど
物事を考えてみると
それは事実ではありません
そんな長くしゃべらなくても
前の紹介でね
死というのは 実感は我々にないとね
鈴木さんが言いましたからね
そういうことなんですよ
こんな実感はないんです
実感はないんだけど
ちょっと考えれば 死なないわけもない ということぐらいはありますよ
それは気持ちではなくて
頭で考えると
やっぱり死ぬでしょう ということは出てきます
ですから
私は死にませんというふうな
変なことを考える人々をおだてて
その人々の機嫌を取るために
天国を妄想するは
極楽堂を妄想するは
また何かの永遠な境地を妄想するとかね
それで問題解決するかというと
解決しないんですね
結局は なぜ解決しないかというと
基本的なところの間違いを 直してないんですね
だから仏教の特色は
嘘は嫌ということ
たとえかっこよくても 嘘は嫌だと
たとえ恐ろしくても 事実を知りたいと
真理を知りたいと
たとえ面白くなくても
たとえ怖いものであろうとも
ごまかしは嫌と
真理　ありのままの事実
本当のことを知りたいというのが 初期仏教の立場なんです
あとでそれまた変わってしまいましたけどね
仏教も人間やらなくちゃいけないんだから
人間みんな死ぬのは嫌な連中だから
やっぱり仏教の中で またいろんな話が出てきたんですよ
慰め言葉が
じゃあそれで どのようにブッダがお釈迦様が死に対応するんですかと
まず必要なのは
このワテワテの頭の中に刷り込まれている
あの真っ赤な嘘をなくすことなんですよ
真っ赤な嘘に基づいて哲学を作ったら
その哲学すべて根拠がなくなっちゃうんです
いいことを言っているかもしれません
例えば世界の平和
人類の平和
みんなに優しくすることやら
いっぱい 宗教の世界でも 哲学の世界でも言ってますよ
決して悪いことじゃないんです
みんなで分かち合って
ものを 財産ね
独り占めにしてはいけませんとか
苦しんでいる人々を助けなくてはいけないんだと
そういう話はいくらでもあります
いい話は
いい話はたくさんあるんだけど
これはどんな土台で
どんなファウンデーションで作った建物かというと
これは 私は死にませんという ファウンデーションの上で
その基礎
そのところの上でできたんだから
あんまりどうかなと
根拠はないでしょうと
ですから
仏教の最初の
狙いというか
目的というかね
それは 私は死にませんという
真っ赤な嘘を消すことなんですよ
ですから
私が死にますよと
それを瞑想しなさいと
ヴィパッサナーは瞑想ではありません
普通 世の中に瞑想もありますけど
ヴィパッサナーという 我々が紹介しているのは
あれは瞑想ではありません
それは 心を育てるちょっとした実践であって
ちゃんとしたプログラムなんですね
瞑想っていうのはそういうちゃんとしたプログラムではなくて
ある特別な訓練なんです
ヨーガは瞑想なんですね
いろんな瞑想法が世の中にあります
いろんなことを念じることも 瞑想の一種なんですね
いろいろ宗教の文句がありますね
南無阿弥陀仏
南無妙法蓮華経
オーム OM/AUM それから何でしたっけね
オームマニパドメフーム Oṃ maṇi padme hūm̐ とかね
仏教系のお祈り文句
呪文がありまして
それはキリスト教にもありますし
他の宗教にもそうやって念じる
お経 文句というか
聖なる言葉っていうものはあるんですよ
それはすごい神秘的な力があるんだとかね
何回でも念じれば念じるほど ご利益が出てくるんだとか
いろんなことを今 言ったりもします
そういう何かを念じること 瞑想の一種なんですね
ですから
仏教で瞑想として 私が死にますと 瞑想しなさい
私が死にますということ
私が死にますと ずっと念じちゃうと
私が死にませんという あの土台が崩れちゃうんですね
それでどうなるかというと
私が死にません
だから 何でもかんでも集めて
人のものでも 何でも自分のものにして
自分のために どんなことでもするんだよ という哲学が 違う哲学になる
私が死にます
では どうすればいいかと
その死ぬというとこまで
死ぬという出来事が起こるまでどうすればいいか という違う哲学が生まれてくるのです
その哲学は完全な平和的で友好的で調和的で
攻撃
競争っていうのは消えちゃうんですよ
だから私が死にますという人にも
マイホーム作れますよ
作れないわけないんだから
私は今 20歳だ
それで 死ぬことは死ぬんだけど
せいぜい
70ぐらいで死ぬでしょうというと
あと 50年ありますね
じゃあ
家を作るんだったら
まあ
50年もてばいいやと
で 50年だけもつ家を作る
400年もつ家は作れません
さらに計算すると
若い時は家を作ると
もうあの
子供 3人がいるんだったら
子供に部屋とかね
いろいろ計画立てて作ったりもしますけど
結局は子供が大きくなっちゃって
みんな出て行っちゃうんですね
家に残るのは夫婦だけなんですよ
それで部屋は
4つぐらいたくさんあるものを作っても
自分の体が弱くなってくる時に
なってくると
家に誰もいない
自分が元気で何でもできる時は
子供たちはいっぱい
もううるさくて
部屋でも喧嘩するし
お兄ちゃんと一緒の部屋は嫌ですよと
私に別の部屋が必要ですよと
そうやって喧嘩までしたりして
親もやっぱり どうせ大きくなっちゃいますからね
一緒はダメだとか思ったりもして 困ったりはするんだけど
それで作りますよ
大きな家を
大きな家を作るんだけど
自分の体が弱くなってくると一人もいない
もう掃除もできない
という状態にもなりますね
ですから
私が死にますということを思う人も 生きてはいるんだけど
その人は 隣の国と戦争しなくちゃいけないんだとかね
相手を殺してまでも
他人のものを取らなくちゃいけないんだとか
そうは思わないんですよ
ここまで頑張らなくたってもいいんだと
人生は無駄にしてはいけないんだということを考えちゃうんですよ
だから いまだに世の中にない生き方っていうのは 出てくるはずなんですよ
私が死にますという
思考から何か考え出すと
私が死にますという瞑想は 実感瞑想ではありません
仏教を
ただなめるだけの先生方は
偉そうに瞑想を指導したりするようなことも 聞いたこともありますけどね
で 私もいろいろ言われたことがあります
死という瞑想を教えてくださいませくれませんか？
とかね 私はまあほとんど聞いてないふりをしたりする
それで結果として
この人はあんまりわからないんだと
かなり批判されたりもする
それであんまりわからないと言ってくると
私にとっては それはすごくありがたい話なんですよ
簡単に何か喋って逃げればいいんだからね
わかってるんだと思ったら えらい期待するでしょ
ですから 私は本当は喋りたくないんです
言うとこんな調子になりますからね
聞きたくない話ばっかりするんです
もっと喋りたい気持ちで喋ったら
そんな調子でもないんです
今日もいい加減で あんまり喋りたくないという気持ちで喋ってます
もう喋りたいと
死について語りたいと思ったら
こんな調子ではないかもしれません
心臓はそれよりは
2 3倍 速く鼓動すると思います
言ったら　ですから
私も そういうことはね
これは大変いい結果になったということで 喜んじゃいますけどね
わかりません と言われたら
仏教のことはね
とにかく私は
私はそういうことじゃなくて
やたらにやっても 意味がないんですよ
やたらに何か念じたからといって
これは何の意味もないんです
ある方に聞いたんだけど
あの すごく瞑想の
教えてくれたんだと
どういうふうに瞑想をなさいます？
と聞いたら
私が死にます
死ぬ
死ぬ と瞑想しているんだと
あ そうですか
なるほど
それで終わったんだけど
人の瞑想に立ち入る必要ないんだからね
そうやっては瞑想になりません
死の瞑想になりません
あれ 変な考え方でね
死ぬ死ぬと思ったって
心の中で死にたくないんですけど
死ぬ 死にたくないんだけど
死ぬ これ
どんどん嫌になっちゃいますよ
何でもいいです
食べたくないんだけど
食べなくちゃいけない
すごく嫌な気持ちになるでしょう
例えば結婚してから
この人と一緒にいたくない
でもいなくちゃいけない
一緒にいたくなくても
これでものすごいストレス溜まって
すごい大変な結果になりますよ
だからそれぐらいでも 心の働きを理解しないで
死ぬ死ぬと瞑想しても
死の瞑想にはなりっこありません
だからそこら辺は すごく危険性がありまして
瞑想の世界では ちゃんと分かった人が 正しく指導するんであって
遊びではちょっと 気をつけた方がいいと思います
それでじゃあ 今日は 死の瞑想の基本的なところ
どういうものかと
瞑想のやり方ではなくてね
瞑想の根拠というかね
基礎 構想は説明しますけど
この死観というのは 死観ですよ
死観というのは
あの 漢字はどんな漢字でしたっけ？
観るでしょうね
で 一つの哲学なんです
一つのビジョンなんです
智慧なんです
感情ではありません
ですから
これ感情になると 精神的におかしくなるんです
そこら辺 気をつけてほしい
これはフィロソフィーであって
フィロソフィー
哲学　ヴィジョン　智慧
ただの気持ちではありません 単純な
単純な気持ちには 何も理屈はないでしょう
例えば 人っていうのは
もう ある
あるカテゴリーの
例えば ロック音楽好きですよと
それは理屈ではなくて
自分がただそれは好き
クラシック音楽は嫌い
それだけのことで
そちらに気持ちだから 理屈はないんです
哲学もないんです
野菜は生で食べるのが好きな人もいて
茹でて食べるのが好きな人もいます
それに何か哲学っていりません
ステーキ食べる時も いろいろあるでしょう
レアかミディアムか生か どうしよう
生でいかん 食べないでしょ
もう生でも食べますけど
いろいろ焼き方がありまして
だから 別に何なのかと聞いても あまり意味がないんですよ
なんであなたはレアでいいんですかと
なんであなたはミディアムのステーキ食べてるんですかと
その人は何かぺちゃぺちゃ言うんだけど
あんまり大した根拠はないんですよ
ミディアムの方が本当に美味しいんですって
レアの方が美味しくないはずでしょうに
そうすると レア焼きのステーキ食べない人間 食べないでしょうに
そんなことないんだから
だからこの気持ちっていうのは哲学ではありません
理屈もない
論理ないんです
論理ないというのは 論理は成り立たない
それは論理を探す必要はありません
あなたは何が好きですかと
それで終わり
なんでなんでと 聞く必要はないんです
あんた昼 何にしますかと
じゃあもう ラーメンにしますよ
あ そう
じゃあラーメンにしましょう
それだけのことで
なぜラーメンにするんですかと
それはラーメンの麺は一つに伸ばしちゃえば
１キロになるんだから
とかね
長さはとか
そんな理屈なんね
今 ないんですよ
スープの中に入れてくれるんだからとか
それ理屈になりません
ご飯食べて別にスープ飲んだって同じことになりますからね
理屈で言えば
美味しいスープ付いてるんだからラーメン好きですよって言ったら 理屈でしょ
だったら ご飯食べてもっと美味しいスープ作って食べればいいでしょう
でもそうにはなりませんね
ラーメン食べたい人にはラーメンですから
ですから
何食べたいかで
それは気持ちですからね
それで ああそうですかと
ここで会話が終わっちゃうんです
それで気持ちの問題 それ
でも死ということは 気持ちではなくて
あるヴィジョンであって
ヴィジョンっていうのは見方見解
だから死観なんです
哲学なんです
だから死の瞑想をする方々は
自分の人生に対する哲学自体が 出来上がるかないかと
それをチェックしながら
この瞑想しなくちゃいけないんですよ
人生に対して
生きるということに対して
自分には違う見方
違う見解
違う哲学が 成り立ってくるでしょうかと
それがこの瞑想の チェックポイントなんです
それで結果でチェックする場合は
死の瞑想をする人々が しない人々より活発
死のことをごまかす人よりは元気
活発　明るい
行動的 それで性格はすごく滑らか
硬くない
それからもう一つ
誰とも ぶつかろうとかね
張り合おうとかね
そういうこともなくなっちゃうんです
すごくにこやかで
明るくて
ニコニコと
軽々と生きてるんです
それは結果
その結果でも
自分の瞑想が正しいか そうでないかとわかるんですよ
瞑想していると
どんどん硬くなって
暗くなって
小さくなって
やる気がなくなっていくと
あれは瞑想ではありません
ですから
死の瞑想は
少々ややこしい瞑想なんです
ですが 初期仏教の方々っていうのは大体 誰でも
やるんです
私の個人のことを言って申し訳ないんだけど
やっと外の世界の物事をわかってくるところで
母親に頭にたたき込まれたのは 死ぬんだという概念なんです
みんな死ぬんだと
なぜその どんな時
その概念を叩き込んだかというと
生まれた赤ちゃんが どんどん大きくなってきて
世の中が見えてくると
どんどん生きるぞというふうな 欲のわがままな人格が出てくるでしょ
あれ欲しい
これ欲しいと
くれなきゃ嫌だとか
ものすごく泣いたりとかね
しゃがみ込んだりとか
一緒に歩く時
母親と 何か自分が好きなものがあって
あれ欲しいと言ったら いいですよ
行きましょうと言ったら しゃがみ込むでしょ
子供たちはもう動かない
時々人の前でも
街の真ん中であろうが
ものすごい声で泣く
これは
1万人 人が集められて
みんなに聞こえる泣き声
それで子供小さなもうお母さんにしたって 若くて普通の女の人だから
もうどうしようもなくなっちゃうんですね
それで負けて はいわかりました とか何とか言って
自分の欲しいものをあげたりする
そういうふうな
どんな人間の性格も そういうふうにできちゃうんですよ
小さい時から
外の世界を見始めて
見え始めて認識し始めると
あれも欲しい
これも欲しい
これは嫌
あれは嫌 というふうな感じで出てくる
だから母っていうのは
何だかんだで サプライヤーですよ
子供に他の人がいないんだから
欲しいものだったらそちらに要求する
英語でサプライヤーと言うんですけど
日本で何と言いますか？
何と言います？
サプライ
供給
供給者と言えますか？
日本語で
供給機関にでもしましょう
とにかくものをサプライする
供給する
自分の
機関は母親なんですね
だから欲しがるものを全部そちらに要求する
くれ くれと
それで人間というのはそんな哲学知識を持っていないんだから
しょうがなくやってはあげますけど
昔の人間だって
自分の母親は
その時 すぐ頭に叩き込んだのは 死ぬという概念なんです
それで必要なもの
欲しいものは何でもくれくれと言って
ものすごい嫌で嫌味で泣いたりしてね
母と喧嘩するっていうことは 何のことなく消えちゃったんです
じゃあそれで 3歳から死ということを叩き込まれた私は すごく暗くて
勉強もしないで
人生は台無しになったかと
そうでもなかったんですけども
どんなとこでも負けず嫌いで とにかく勝ってやるぞという感じで生きてきたんだから
2番目にはなりませんと
教室でも勉強する時でも
勉強するんだったら 結果は1番を目ざすんだと
だから それは決して人の生き方に 何か悪い影響を与えるわけじゃないんですね
で とにかく何のためにそんな話をしたんですかというと
仏教の世界では 一般的に 誰でも死ぬんだということを教えてあげる
ですから
初期仏教を実践する人々とは 話しやすいんですよ
商売でも何でも
人の意見
相談しやすいんです
人の意見も聞く
それで 自分の意見だけ通ってほしいとも思わないんです
一応 意見なんか組み合わせて
曲げるところは曲げる
曲げてはいけないところは ちゃんとこういうことですよと ちゃんと言っておく
我が道 一人で歩けっていうことは なくなっちゃうんですね
かなり柔らかくなります
心が
とにかく
死という 死の瞑想っていうのは しなくちゃいけないことなんですね
だからそれ瞑想して
我々の心の中に書かれている
厳密に刷り込まれている 私は死にませんという概念を 捨てなくてはならないんですね
それで瞑想のやり方の場合は
はっきりした決まりがないんですね
私は死ぬ ということで
大体この思考を刺激するように瞑想するんですよ
ある経典 持ってきましたけど
この瞑想する場合は
生命すべてという 一切の生命が死んでしまうんだ というところから始まるんです
そこからの哲学でしょ
これ Suttanipāta の真理の言葉として訳されています
中村元先生
579番　番号 振ってます
579という番号を振っている　8番目の経典
もう一つありますけど
ちょっと時間なくて印刷できなかったんです
その経典の名前も面白い名前で Sallasutta なんですね (Snp3.8 矢経)
sallaっていうのは 昔の戦いに行く時は 長い 人を刺す何か持っていくんですね
槍みたいなもの
なんて言います
槍 槍持ってますよ
それで敵を槍で刺すんでしょ
sallaっていうのは槍という意味なんですね
自分は槍で もう刺されてるんですよ
槍が体に刺して向こう側まで行ったならば
どうなるんですかね
ほんのちょっと 生きてるかもしれませんけど
もう決まってるんですね
どうなるかということは
で 579から短い経典で598まであります
少々この気持ちを理解できるために ちょっとだけ読みますけど
Animittamanaññātaṁ,
maccānaṁ idha jīvitaṁ;
Kasirañca parittañca,
tañca dukkhena saṁyutaṁ.
もしパーリ語がわかる方々がいるならば
この経典を覚えて唱えればいいんです
すごい詩なんですよ
Animittamanaññātaṁ
もう決まりがない
とても不確定であってわからないんだ
maccānaṁ idha jīvitaṁ
人間のこの世の中の命というものは 不確定であって
あまり決まりませんと
Kasirañca parittañca
kasiran
やっと生きてるだけだと
すごい苦労して生きてるんだと
parittan
そんな大した人生もできません
小さいんだと
スモール　parittanっていうのは
一人の人間の命っていうのは
ほんのわずかな小さなものだと
tañca dukkhena saṁyutaṁ
その生きることも かなり苦しみで生きていなくちゃいけないんだと
Na hi so upakkamo atthi,
yena jātā na miyyare;
Jarampi patvā maraṇaṁ,
evaṁdhammā hi pāṇino.
こういうのは我々は葬式で使うんです
スリランカだったら葬式で説法するんですよ
15分ぐらい
20分ぐらい
その説法なんかのタイトルにするのは
こういうだいたいこの経典なんです
私も覚えておかなくちゃ
まあ一応一応覚えてるんだけど
いくらか
Na hi so upakkamo atthi,
yena jātā na miyyare;
yena jātā na miyyare
生まれた人が見えないようにする
upakkamo
どんなからくりもない
na hi ありません
生まれた人が死なない
死なないようにする
何か対策
方法　何かからくり
何もありません
Jarampi patvā maraṇaṁ
年取って死ぬんだと
evaṁdhammā hi pāṇino
生命の特色っていうのはそんなもんだよと
だから生命として見るんですよ
すべての生命
やっぱり死なないようにするという方法はありません
どんな生命でも年取って死んじゃうんだと
次 Phalānamiva pakkānaṁ,
pāto patanato bhayaṁ;
Evaṁ jātāna maccānaṁ,
niccaṁ maraṇato bhayaṁ.
phalānamiva pakkānaṁ
木の実ですね
もし熟したならば
黄色くなったならば
pāto patanato bhayaṁ
朝はもうないかもしれませんと
枝の先っぽに　落ちるんだと
だからその当時で
あの
日本で黄色くなる果物といえば ほとんど有名な一種ですね
あれ 柿ですか
柿は我が強いんだからね
なかなか落ちませんけど
黄色くなったらすぐ落ちる果物っていうのは いっぱいあるんですよ
インドにいっぱいあるのは マンゴなんですね
マンゴはあれ
ついてるところ
すごく細いんですよ
マンゴが黄色くなったら プチンと落ちるんです
だから熟したマンゴを食べたければ
マンゴの木の方に朝行けば 下に落ちてるんですよ
落ちてるものは拾って
そのまま洗って 食べられます
ちょうどいいところに熟しているんです
だからもういっぱいありましたから
あるんだから
今もインドでどこへ行ってもマンゴ
マンゴばっかり見えますからね
マンゴーの黄身から なんとなく黄色いマンゴーを見たら
まあ明日ないだろうと
落ちるんです
そのように果物が黄色くなったら落ちるんだよ
Evaṁ jātāna maccānaṁ
そのように人が生まれたら
生まれたならば
niccaṁ maraṇato bhayaṁ
ずっと死ということがついているんだと
死ぬんだよと
生まれたらいつかわからない
ずっとついているんだ
Yathāpi kumbhakārassa,
katā mattikabhājanā;
Sabbe bhedanapariyantā, evaṁ maccāna jīvitaṁ.
これも昔インドの 周りを見て言ってる偈なんですよ
kumbhakārassa っていうのは
この器を作る人
だいたい土で作るんですよ
普通の食器というか
料理用の皿　皿ではなくて
料理を作る鍋とかね
日本の土鍋みたいな
潰しても潰せないぐらい 頑固で焼いて作るわけじゃないんです
だから日本の土鍋とあんまり一緒に考えないでください
素焼きというんですか
ただ土そのものを焼く
だからすぐ壊れる
だからこの普通の土を練って入れ物を作って
kumbhakāraっていうのはその仕事なんですよ
この土鍋を作る人はkumbhakāraという
kumbhakāraが作る鍋が
作った瞬間からもう壊れる可能性あるんだと
それから必ず壊れる
どれぐらい弱いというと
ちょっと石一つでもポチンと落ちたら穴が開けるんですよ
それぐらいもろいんです
今もずっと使ってます
そういうものは
だからもう値段も安いし
厳密に温度を調整した
この あれ
何て言いますか
窯で焼く必要ないんだから
一旦作って
それを積み重ねて
何かもう薪とかなんとか入れてただ燃やしちゃえばいいんです
それでいくらかは硬くなる
それでもって料理作ったりします
買ってきたものは 何か水は漏れるようだったら捨てちゃって
他のものを買ってきます
あまり文句も言わない
すぐ壊れる場合もあるし
まあ壊れなかったら
まあそれなりに
2 3年
4年 5年
10年使うものもありますけど
10年間使うと 毎日 火の上にあるんだから
だから頑固 硬くなったと
そうでもないんです
子供でも走ってたところに ちょっと足に引っかかったら もう割れてるんですから
そういうふうに kumbhakāra が作る
なんて言いますか
こういう食器がすぐ壊れるように
人間の命も壊れてしまいます
Daharā ca mahantā ca,
ye bālā ye ca paṇḍitā;
Sabbe maccuvasaṁ yanti,
sabbe maccuparāyaṇā.
daharā 赤ちゃんであろうが
mahantā 大人であろうが
bālā 頭の良い人であろうが
paṇḍitā 賢者であろうが
sabbe maccuvasaṁ
みんな死にますよ
sabbe maccuparāyaṇā
みんなもう死で終わりますよと
Tesaṁ maccuparetānaṁ,
gacchataṁ paralokato;
Na pitā tāyate puttaṁ,
ñātī vā pana ñātake.
そのように死
必ず死んでしまう人々が 死んであの世に行く時は
あの世に行った時は
あの世に行かなくちゃいけない
それは単なる言葉で
死んだらあの世に行ったとね
他界しましたという言葉ですからね
死ぬ運命の人々は 他界するところで
Na pitā tāyate puttaṁ
お父さんにも自分の息子を守ることはできないんだと
例えば自分の息子が死んでいるんでしょ？
死にかけているでしょ
いくら自分が父親だと言ったとしても
どうすることもできないんだと
ñātī vā pana ñātake
あるいは自分にはすごい親戚がいるんだと思っても
親戚にも何もすることもできない
我が子は死にかけていても 母親に守ってあげることもできないし
父親に守ってあげることもできないし
他の親戚に守ってあげることはできないでしょうと
Pekkhataṁyeva ñātīnaṁ,
passa lālapataṁ puthu;
Ekamekova maccānaṁ,
govajjho viya nīyati.
pekkhataṁyeva ñātīnaṁ
親戚が待っているのに
例えば子供なんかの場合は
自分の母親
両親がもうそばに待っているのに
あるいは年取って死ぬ場合は
自分の子供たちやら 他の親戚が みんな自分を囲んで待っているのに
passa lālapataṁ puthu
見てみなさいよと
ekamekova
その人が一人で死ななくちゃいけないんだと
もうたとえで言えば
govajjho viya nīyati
あの牛を屠殺すると
この屠殺する人が 牛を引っ張って連れて行くでしょ
そんな感じで この人を引っ張って 死へ連れて行かれるんだと
Evamabbhāhato loko,
Maccunā ca jarāya ca;
Tasmā dhīrā na socanti,
Viditvā lokapariyāyaṁ.
このように世の中 悩ませている
悩んでいる
苦しんでいる
何に苦しんでますか？
Maccunā ca jarāya ca
死ぬことと老いることで 世の中は大変いじめられている
すべての生命が
すべての生命はこの
2つで苦しんでいるんですよ
一切の生命が死と老いること
老死　老死っていうのは
まあ老死ではなくて
あの　まあ老死
老と死というのはもう大変ないじめで
いじめ役で
もう必ず すべての生命を苦しませているんですね
tasmā dhīrā na socanti
賢者が 頭のいい人が na socanti 悲しまない
そんなことを
別にみんなの運命だから 悲しまないと
これは世の中の常であると
悲しむべきものではありませんと
Yassa maggaṁ na jānāsi,
āgatassa gatassa vā;
Ubho ante asampassaṁ,
niratthaṁ paridevasi.
Yassa maggaṁ na jānāsi,
āgatassa gatassa vā;
どこから来たか
どこへ行ったか
さっぱりわかりませんと
わかりますか？
我々はどこから来たんですかと
死んでからどこへ行くかと
どこから来たかもわからない
どこへ行ったかもわからない
さっぱりわからない
この生命に対して 両方わからない
niratthaṁ paridevasi
泣くのは無意味だよと
自分の子供であろうと どこから来たやつか わからないでしょうに
これで死んでから どこに行くかもわからない
なんで泣くんですかね
それで泣くのは無意味だよと
Paridevayamāno ce,
Kiñcidatthaṁ udabbahe;
Sammūḷho hiṁsamattānaṁ,
Kayirā ce naṁ vicakkhaṇo.
もし人が死んだら泣くならば
泣くことで何か得られるんだ
何か得するならば
人が死んだらすごく泣く
泣くことで何か得するならば
何を得するんですかと
ただ疲れるだけ
ただ疲れるだけだと
泣いて
Na hi ruṇṇena sokena,
Santiṁ pappoti cetaso;
そこで仏教の言いたいところがあります
Na hi ruṇṇena sokena
すごい悲しんで泣くことで
Santiṁ pappoti
心の安らぎは得られませんと
人が死んだところで悲しくて 泣いて泣き崩れたところで 何も得られません
泣き崩れると 心の安らぎが得られませんと
Bhiyyassuppajjate dukkhaṁ
ただ自分の苦しみがさらに増えるだけですよと
死んだのは他人なんですけど
残された人々は さらに苦しむ
それだけ
泣けば泣くほど苦しむだけでしょうと
で 体も壊れるんだと
他人が死んで 自分の健康を失うことは バカらしいんだっていうことを言ってるんですよ
人が死んだとしても 元気でやれと生きている者に言ってるんです
泣いて苦しむ必要はないんだと
Kiso vivaṇṇo bhavati,
Hiṁsamattānamattanā;
Na tena petā pālenti,
Niratthā paridevanā.
泣くと kiso 痩せちゃうんだと
これはいいことですよ
こちらで痩せるっていうことは いい意味で言ってるわけじゃなくて
今の人々は食べ過ぎだから 痩せるのはいいことなんですけど
あの健康を失うっていうことだからね
vivaṇṇo bhavati
ものすごく醜くなるんですよ
泣いて 泣いて
もう消化もできなくて
体力もなくなって
体もほとんど醜くなる
それから精神的に
hiṁsamattānamattanā
自分で自分の心を苦しましてるんだと
na tena petā pālenti
自分が泣いたからって
死んだ人には何の役にも立ちませんと
petā っていうのは 餓鬼という言葉で訳しますけど
死んだ人々にはだいたい petā という言葉を使ってますね
だから死んだ人に回向することは 供養するとかは別なんですけど
泣いたからといって 成仏できるわけでも何でもないんだと
全然 死んだ人の役にも立ちませんと
niratthā paridevanā
泣くことは無意味だよと
Sokamappajahaṁ jantu,
Bhiyyo dukkhaṁ nigacchati;
Anutthunanto kālaṅkataṁ,
Sokassa vasamanvagū.
死ぬことで悲しむ
死ぬことで悩む
それは捨てない限りは
さらに苦しまなくちゃいけない
だからどうせ生きることは苦しみでしょう
その生きる上では たくさん自分の親しい人々は死んでいくでしょう
それにまた泣いて苦しんじゃうと
生きる苦しみは倍 3倍
4倍 10倍に
なるだけですよと
Anutthunanto kālaṅkataṁ,
Sokassa vasamanvagū.
死んだ人のことを 思い出して
思い出していること
anutthunanto っていうのはそういうことなんです
死んだ人のことを毎回 朝晩 思い出しては思い出すとなる
そういうことでおって
ただ苦しみの奴隷になるだけ
悲しみの奴隷になるだけですよと
Aññepi passa gamine,
Yathākammupage nare;
Maccuno vasamāgamma,
Phandantevidha pāṇino.
他の人々も見てみなさいよと
世の中を見てみなさいよ
いろんな人が死んでるでしょう
どんな生命でも
動物でも
いつでも震えているんだと
何に震えているの？
死の恐怖感で
動物でも餌取りながら怖がっているでしょ
鳥を見ても
餌取りながら周り見たりと
あれ 殺されるかないか見ているんですよ
落ち着いて食べることもできないんですよ
動物には
人間にはできますけど
でも戦争があったりすると落ち着いて食べられないでしょう
1年前のボスニアやら そういうところにしても
今もいろんなところで
まあ落ち着いて寝ることもできない
もうどこから爆弾をしかけてくるか わかりませんから
ですから
動物の世界を見ても
他の世界を見てくださいよと
みんないつでも震えているんだと
死で
Yena yena hi maññanti,
Tato taṁ hoti aññathā;
Etādiso vinābhāvo,
Passa lokassa pariyāyaṁ.
で ここでまたある哲学なんですよ
世の中の有様 見なさいよと
passa lokassa pariyāyaṁ
世の中の有様見なさいよ
yena yena hi maññanti
何か思ったら
こうなりたい
ああいう風になりたい
このようになりたいと思ったら
tato taṁ hoti aññathā
全く反対のことになるんだと
思うことが全く 逆さになってしまっちゃいますよと
例えば 美しくなりたいと 世の中に売っているお化粧品はね
使い放題 使っちゃどうなるんですかね
皮膚が荒れて
結局 生まれつきの皮膚が病気になってしまうでしょ
トカゲの皮膚のようになるんです
私はもう何人か見たんですよ
皮膚は すごい綺麗な女優さんでしたけど
で ちょっと何十年前の話
ニコニコといろいろ喋ってはしましたけど
ちょっと近寄るなよっていう気持ちがあるんですよ
もう大変
日本で有名な女優さん
でもまあいい
親しく喋れません
近寄るなよと
なんだか皮膚はトカゲの皮膚ではないかという感じがするんですよ
で なぜかというと
あれ お化粧塗りすぎ
塗りすぎ
塗りすぎで
映画なんかに テレビドラマなんかに出なくちゃいけないんだから
この光を反射して綺麗に映してもらうために塗って
そこら辺ちょっとでも もう落としてみたら
もう皮膚の状態っていうのは大変なんですよ
それは余計な話でね
哲学的な話ではないんだけど
一応 哲学的に言えば 世の中の有様を見てみなさいよと
人が何か希望すると
結果は全く逆さまで
もう全く違う結果になるんじゃないんでしょうかと
etādiso vinābhāvo
そのようにすべてなくなっちゃうんだと
それから 人間は一番 希望するものは
死なないこと
それは はっきりと裏切られるんです
死ぬんだと
Api vassasataṁ jīve,
Bhiyyo vā pana māṇavo;
Ñātisaṅghā vinā hoti,
Jahāti idha jīvitaṁ.
もし人が頑張って頑張って
vassasataṁ jīve
100年間生きていたとすると
bhiyyo vā pana
あるいは100年以上も生きていたとしたらどうなるかというと
自分には誰もいなくなっちゃうんだと
だからこの100歳飛んじゃったら
自分の奥さんはいない
子供も死んでるとか
一緒に学校に行った人々
一緒に 本当に 自分に親しい仲間たち
親戚はいないんですよ
孫 ひ孫いてもね
全然もう知らんですからね
そういう人々は
後から来た人だから
そんなに親しみ感じません
だから長生きしちゃったらどうなるかと
一人ぼっちになるんだと
他の人は死んでしまいますから
Tasmā arahato sutvā,
Vineyya paridevitaṁ;
Petaṁ kālaṅkataṁ disvā,
Neso labbhā mayā iti.
それで arahato sutvā
悟った人々に聞きなさいよ
聞いて vineyya paridevitaṁ
死に対して悩むことをなくそう
人が死んだんだからといって悩むなかれと
泣くなかれと
聖者たちの 悟った人々の話を聞いてみなさいよと
Petaṁ kālaṅkataṁ disvā,
Neso labbhā mayā iti.
死んだ人を見て
これをどういう風に訳せばいいかな
死んだ人を見ると
これっきりで
その人はもう私たちのものではないんだと
もう死んじゃった 終わったよと
時々人が泣くと
私の息子はどこへ行ったんでしょうかとか
インド文化だったらね
帰ってくれとかね
どこへ行ったんでしょうとか
そういうふうな泣き言葉もありますよ
それについて言ってるかもしれません
日本の方々
どのような風かわかりませんけどね
ですから
これ インド的な泣き方かもしれませんし
死んだ人を見たら
帰ってくるわけじゃないんだと
もう行っちゃったと
もう終わったと 言って落ち着いてみましょうと
Yathā saraṇamādittaṁ,
Vārinā parinibbaye;
Evampi dhīro sapañño,
Paṇḍito kusalo naro;
Khippamuppatitaṁ sokaṁ,
Vāto tūlaṁva dhaṁsaye.
もし何か火が燃えていると
我々はさっと水をかけて それを消す
そのように智慧のある人が
上手な人が
心に死に対して悩みが生まれたら すぐ消しなさいと
泣いたり
またいろいろ文句言ったり
なんで早く死んだんだろう
なんで早く逝ったんだろうとか
私一人残して
なんであんた一人？
そういうふうなことを思ったりするでしょう
そういうことを思ったりして
自分を暗くするならば
それであなたは幸せになりませんと
あなたはさらにこの矢で
ひどい矢で
あなたはさらにきつく刺されるだけですよと
それでどうしますか？
abbūḷhasallo
この矢を抜きましょう
死ぬのは嫌だということ
その場合は
死ぬのは嫌だということがあると
もう矢に刺されていますよ
苦しみになるんです
死ぬのは嫌だと思ったら
ですから
死ぬのは嫌だという この矢を抜きましょう
santiṁ pappuyya cetaso
心を安らかにしなさいよと
Sabbasokaṁ atikkanto
世の中の状況を乗り越えましょう
asoko hoti nibbuto
来る悲しみがない
nibbuta は涅槃のこと　落ち着きという言葉ですけどね
心の落ち着き
心の安らぎを体験しなさいと
だからこれは死の瞑想なんですよ
だから結構違うでしょ
死の見方
哲学的に見ているんです
感情的に見ているわけじゃないんです
論理的に見ているんです
人が死んで泣くんだったら
あんた損するんだと
泣いて何が得られるかと
あんた苦しむだけですよ
そういうふうに見て瞑想するんですね
もう一つ 瞑想のやり方ありまして
この例えばロウソクの炎があっても いつ消えるかわからない
例えば外でロウソクを一つ立てておくと
どこから風が吹くかわからないでしょうし
いつ風が吹いてくるかわからない
そのように私の命もいつ死ぬかわからないんだよと
風が吹いてきて死ぬかもしれません
ろうそくだから
あるいは倒れて ろうそくの炎が消えるかもしれません
風が吹かなくても
ろうそくのろうが消えたところで 消えてしまいますからね
命っていうのはそのようなものだと
それから石を一つか二つ 割ったならば
もう二度と戻らないように
確実に死んじゃったら また戻ってくると
この世で生き返るということもありませんと
水の上に書いた絵のごとく
書くと同時に 消えてしまいますね
そのように 人々っていうのは 生まれたら確実に死んでしまうんだと
命は稲妻のように短いんだと
弓から放った矢が 戻ることないんだと
先に行って落ちるんだと
そのように 生まれた人には 死に向かっていくしか方法ないんだと
そういうふうに
この死に対して哲学的に これは一般的なものだというふうに見るんです
当たり前だ
常識だ 何のこともないんだ
当たり前のこと 常識なことはニュースにもならない
例えば 明日の新聞で大スクープだ
今日は日曜日だと出ますか？
タイトルなんかは
出ません　当たり前だから
明日 日曜日ということは　スクープでも何でもないんです
あるいは明日
大スクープだ
今日は太陽がもう何時何分かわかりませんけど
もう太陽が出ましたとかね
毎日のことだから
もう当たり前だから
そういうものはニュースにならないんですよ
ニュースになるのは
お母さんが子供を殺したとかね
そういう ありえないと思うものはニュースになります
びっくりもします
何だろうかと
例えば日本で どこかのコンビニに強盗が入ってお金を持って行ったら
それはニュースになります
もし毎日どこかでコンビニがやられるんだったら
全然ニュースにならないんです
だから びっくりするものじゃないんです
みんな死ぬんだという
この我々は認めたくない
この事実を心でとにかく頑張って認める
認めて落ち着く
あ そう死んだの
それぐらいで
私も後から来るんだからと
まあ
そんな大したことはないと
みんなの運命だと
そこにもう 神様の話やら 仏様の話やら
もう迎えに来る話やら
どんな もうSF映画みたいなね
話は持ってくる必要はないんだっていうのは
初期仏教の見方なんです
それは死に対するアプローチなんですね
それで自分には死の実感ないんだから
当たり前だからね
面白いことって
自分が死んだことは一度もないのに
死ぬのは怖いと言うでしょ
死ぬのはやっぱり怖いんだと
これはもう死んだこともないのに よくも言うんですからね
なぜそう言うんですか？
頭に死にませんよ ということが書かれているでしょう
書かれているんだけど
死ぬかもしれませんなと思っちゃったら怖くなるんですよ
ですから
死なないということは消した方がいいんですね
それは正しい見方になります
すごい明るい哲学も生まれてきます
明るい生き方
明るい世界というものは出てきます
見方がものすごく変わるんです
で まあ
これは死の瞑想についてなんですけど
で どうしますか
このターミナルの問題にちょっと触れたいんですけど
えっと　ちょっと休憩
疲れていらっしゃるならば
ちょっと10分ぐらい休憩にして 後半に行きます
じゃあ それでは後半に入ります
で 後半に入る前にもう一つ
自分の死に対して どのように瞑想するかという場合は
よく他人の死を観察する
いくらでもこの世の中で
人であろうが動物であろうが
死んじゃいますよ
いくらでも見えるはずなんです
魚屋さんに行っても見えるでしょうに
死体は見えないというならば
築地ですか
そちらへでも見学にでも行ってみれば
どれぐらい死んでるかと
と見えるでしょう
見たら人間というのは全く 非論理的なことを考える
このマグロはおそらく
500万円だよとかね
これはすごい美味しいですよとかね
そういう ものすごい残酷なことばっかり考える
どれぐらいお金になるかとかね
そういう考え方はもう無知的な考え方で
智慧の 哲学的な見方じゃないんですね
だから仏教で死の瞑想したい人々に この一言を教えているんですよ
Yathā etaṃ, tathā idaṃ という言葉 覚えておいてください
あの　これはあの
一つのまた瞑想の言葉なんです
私は誰かが死んだことを見る
見たら yathā etaṃ
yathā etaṃ
これは どのようになったか
tathā そのように idaṃ これも
ただ それだけ
なかなか英訳もできないんですよ
なぜならば 動詞もない
ただ言葉 4つだけ
でもパーリ語だったら それで意味がちゃんと通じる
etaṃ というのは
「それは」 前にあるもの
イダン idaṃ というのは
「これは」 ということ
「それ」 「これ」って意味なんです
「それは」どのようになったか
「これも」そのようになるんだと
だから自分が 例えば誰かのね
亡くなったら（葬式に）行くでしょ？
行ったら 遺体を見たら いろんなことをくだらんことを言うんじゃなくて
あ 「それは」と「これは」と思えば
それぐらいのことだよ
「それ（遺体）」はこの
このようになった
そのようにこれも 「この体」もなるんだと
それは死の瞑想の仕方なんです
だからこのバカでかい
あれ 何でしたか？
あの魚 このマグロ
見たら これはまあすごいいいもので
もう 1,000万円ぐらいの価値があるんじゃないかなとかね
と思うんじゃなくて
それは今どのようになっているかと 死んで死体になっていると
これからぶつ切りにして 競りに出して
みんな買って食べるんだと
これは食べるわけじゃないんだけど
もう誰も食べてくれませんけど
これもそのようになるんだと
特に人間死んだらまた必ず同じことでしょう
燃やすか埋めるかと
あ こちらもそのようになるんだと
ですから
日本風に言えば
私も死ぬんだという一言でいいんです
それは死んだ時 観察するんですよ
だからすごいクールなんですよ
死体に対してアプローチが　感情的じゃないんです
それはもうなかなか
しょうがないんですけど
あまり美しく
すごい感情的で
歌を流しながら葬式やるとかね
そういうのはないんですね
あんまり
すごくクールで淡々と日常茶飯事のことのように遺体を処理する
それだけ
仏教の見方はね
ですから
もう自分の知ってる親しい人々が死んじゃったら
必ず皆様が参加する
そちらには　行ったら
なんで早く死んだだろうとかね
天国で見守ってくださいとかね
そういうのはもう嘘の世界で根拠ない
ただ人間の慰めだけ
気休めの言葉だけなんですね
死体の前で論文 書いて持っていって
論文というか
作文を持っていって読むと
ああいうのはもう文化的にやってますけど
哲学的に 別に何か仏教哲学的に 何も意味があるわけじゃないんですね
まあ時々葬式
その遺体がある時にやる場合もあるし
1ヶ月後で写真と位牌だけ入れてやる場合もあるでしょう
もう位牌の前で
写真の前で
なんとか人の名前を読んで
あなたは なんとかとか
もうそのどんな言葉で言うんですか
その場合は
え？弔辞
弔辞の言葉 言いますけど
それはもう勝手に遊びですからね
どんな遊びでもよろしいですけど
それは遊びだけなんですよ
遊びだと思ったら私も認めますよ
例えば ある人が死ぬ時
私を火葬する時は この曲を流してくださいと言うならば
じゃあ気持ちよくやりましょうというならばいいんですよ
遊びだったら
それ以上意味があると思ったら困るんですね
弔辞も 自分たちの文学能力を出すところだと思って
そこを競い合っても構いませんだけど
死んだ人に何の役にも立ちません
まず　ですから
遊びだったらいいんですけど
それ以上のことを考えてはいけません
それで この死の瞑想っていうのは
私もこのようになる
この体もこのようになると言って
ほんのちょっと自分の死も ほんのちょっとイメージをしてみる
で すごい変化がわかるんです
私は一回 事故を起こして人が死んで
その見たんだけど
死んだ時ではなくて
もう遺体はもうとっくに運ばれてあったんだけど
で ほんのちょっと一部 脳細胞だと
脳みそだと思いますけど
ほんのちょっと見えたんですね
道路に残っていて
それ見えた瞬間で
ある若者が今 死んだだろうと
ということは
すぐもう
なんとなく体に入っちゃって
そこで あの脳みその一部見たら
これにはもう今 命も何もない
いかに命っていうのは儚くて
瞬時に消えるものでしょう と言った途端
それは自分の命になったんですよ
その時もいっぱいファイルを持って
重いカバンを持って 大学で講義があります
その講義をするために 行った途中なんですよ
もうバスが止まっちゃったんですね
そこら辺で　止まったところで
窓から見ただけなんですけど
そこで自分たちがもう張り切って生きるために
やってる
この生き方はいかに儚くて
いかに瞬間で全て消えるかということがパッと入っちゃって
なんか体からあったいろんなもう汚れのようなものというか
この執着のようなものはサッと消えて
もう何もない世界がその瞬間に生まれちゃうんですね
だから欲もないし
怒りもない
その代わり何かあるかって
何でもない
やっぱり命っていうのはそんなものだと
だからその人によってインパクトはね
それぞれ違いますけど
もう一回 私にあったのは
一緒に大学で勉強していた 同じ年のある若いお坊さんが死んじゃったんですね
白血病で
大学卒業して1年目か2年目かと思います
だから歳も同じで
みんな20代でしょ
その人のお寺に行って
もう何もしきたりもしないで
私はただ遺体の前で こういうふうに手を組んで見たんですけど
同じ年だからね
もうそちらにその人がいないんですよ
ただ遺体だけ
やっぱりなんか見方がえらい違うんだよ
私の見方が
私はそこに自分の死を置き換えて見る
それは死の瞑想なんだ
だから小さい時からもう やっと言葉なんかわかるようになってきたところで
もう叩き込まれちゃったんだから
どうしてもそうなっちゃうんですね
遺体見ちゃうと
悲しいとかということでもないんです
なんで死んだんだろうとかね
そういうことでもないし
当たり前のことでしょうし
だから自分も別に そういう状況から離れてるわけじゃないんだと
だから瞑想するようなことは
Yathā etaṁ, tathā idaṁ. という言葉なんですね
これはどのようになっているか
そのようにこれもなるんだ　いって
この常識に持ってくるんですよ
本当の常識に
死ということは
自分の死の実感はないんです
自分が死ぬ時は一回きりだから
だから死を見るたびに
私も死ぬんだから
ただ それだけ
だから人間の死を見た方が 一番よろしいんですけど
もう何 見たら
例えば よくあるでしょと
子供が すごく可愛がっていた犬か猫が死んじゃったら
子供は泣いたりする
それで親が 天国に行ったんだから
天国にいてあなたのことをじーっと待ってる
見ているんだからね
大丈夫だとか
あんな嘘なんで言うんですかと
とにかく子供を慰めるために いろいろごまかしを
もう天国で待ってるんだとかね
じっとそばにいるんだとかね
死んでもとかね
だから大丈夫だ
心配する必要はないんだとかね
そうじゃなくて
本当に言うべきなのは
みんな死ぬよ
君も死んじゃうよ
泣いたって ワンちゃんだから10歳で死んじゃうし
あんた人間だから
あとそろそろ60年ぐらい経ったら死ぬでしょう
その前でも事故を起こしたりとかね
もう何かちょっと 階段から足を滑らせたりして
死ぬかもしれませんよ というふうに言ったら 泣かないんですよ
なんでそれをやらないかと
事実でしょう
だから子供っていうのは 小さい時はすごい
真理を教えてくれると 大人を信頼するんですよ
子供に我々はすごい嘘を教えるでしょ
だから
それなくて
単なる事実をそのまま言っちゃうと
子供はそうとわかってもわからなくても
事実を言ったら納得するんですよ
あんたわかったかって
これはまた別な話で
で あの
例えば私はどこから来たんですか？
こうのとり持ってきたんだよというのは とんでもない話なんですね
だから若者たち
ばれないよと
あんたはこちらから生まれたんだからと
だからわからないかもしれませんけど
それは事実だから
子供はその時落ち着いちゃうんですね
ですから
子供にでもあんな変なことじゃなくて
事実をそのまま言っちゃえばいいんです
だって子供は死ぬのは嫌だと
嫌と言ったって どうしようもないでしょうにと
何言うんだよ
このバカと言っちゃえば
当たり前の事実だと すぐわかってくれるんですよ
だから 仏教の世界と 普通の信仰を重んじている世界の差が そちらにあるんですね
我々は何のことなく 事実そのものを言っちゃう
そこで我が無しに わがままもない
性格で 謙虚で すぐ頑張る人間にはなります
そういうことだから
当たり前
どうということない という
この明るい見方
仏教で前 説明した経典でも 泣くな
泣くのはバカだよということを言っていたんだから
泣いてあんた得するのは ただ疲れることだけですよと
さらに体を苦しめるだけですよ
みんな死んじゃうんだと
泣くことによって 心の落ち着きが出てこないんだと いうことだから
いつでも我々は朝 太陽が出てびっくりする人がいないし
あの 何も普通のことに 何一つびっくりしないでしょ
たまたまどこかで地震が起きたなかで
そんなにびっくりもしませんし
で ごく普通にいるんだからね
そういう感じで
それぐらい死ということは当たり前のことだから
まずびっくりしないこと
驚かないこと
心の落ち着きを守ることは すごく必要なんです
ですから
死の瞑想は一番やるべき時期は 若い時なんです
年取ってくると
もうあまりにも長い間 騙されて
馬鹿げた生き方で生きてきたんだから 理解できないんですよ
あまりにも頭が悪すぎて
ですから
できるだけ早いうち
死ぬ だから私はみんなに遠慮しちゃうんですね
死の瞑想なんかは
もう遅いんじゃないかなと
で 子供なんか聞いたら すぐ教えるんです
死って何なのかと
で 頭にはちゃんと入ります
できるだけ若い時にやった方がいいんです
で あの
危険なところもありますから
例えば もう99歳のおばあちゃん
おばあさんはこれから死の瞑想しなさいと言ったら
おばあちゃんにとっては 目の前の事実だから
高齢者が混乱する
おばあちゃんがせっかく極楽堂に行こうかなと思っていたところでね
あの心の落ち着くはなくなるかもしれませんし
ですから
どんなものを瞑想にしたとしても
やっぱり時期と そこありますからね
向き不向きもありますし
年によってもあるし
大体 仏教の中でもこの若い人々を元気な時
すごい体力があって自信満々の時は 死の瞑想をとことんしてみて
あのわがまま高慢を飛ばしちゃうんですね
で より立派な落ち着いている人間になる
それからわかりやすい言葉で言うのは
こういうことを言いたいんです
赤ちゃんなんかは
母親がちょっと手で顔を隠して
いない　いない
いないと言っただけで 笑うでしょ？
いないわけでも何でもないのに
ものすごく笑っちゃうんですね
手も足も動かしながら
だから 死ぬ時もそれぐらい笑って死んでほしい
明るく
赤ちゃんは別に何も
一般的には それほど悩みも何もあるわけじゃないし
じっと母親そばにいるし
安心しているし
だから笑える
物事は当たり前だと思ったら 安心できるでしょう
で 昔の人間みたいに 夜になってから
原始時代で人々が 聞いた話なんですけど
いたわけじゃないんだから
あの 太陽が沈むと お祈りするんです
もし明日 出てこなかったら大変だから
どうか我々の罪を許して
明日も おいでになってくださいと
と神様にお祈りする
それで ぴったしお祈りを聞いて
次の日も 太陽が現れるんですよ
もっと不思議なのは
こちらから沈んだ太陽が 全く違う方向から出てくるんだから
これは不思議でたまらなかったんですね
昔の人にとっては
で 今は日の出を見て拝む人はいるんだけど
あれは原始時代からね
続いている遺伝子のあれだと思いますけどね
まあ一応感動しますね
で 私はすごい綺麗だから
あ すごい綺麗だなと
なんと美しいかと思う時ありますけど
で 私は自分の国は西の方にいるんだから
日の出よりは 日没はよく見るんですよ
それで海の中に太陽が入っちゃうと
ものすごいもう美しいんです
で 向こうは暑い国だからね
もう空にかける色の数々っていうのは
もうすごい
もう言えないほど綺麗なんですけど
ですから
それはそれで
今はあまり ごく普通の当たり前のことで
ですから
日の出やら 日没やら
ごく普通の当たり前のような感じで
人の生まれも死も 同じ 当たり前のことだと見ること
理解すること
その角度で見ること
人が生まれたら
ああ もう万々歳で 喜んじゃうでしょう
同じ気持ちで 人が死ぬ時も いなくてはならないんです
だから言えないんですけど
おばあちゃん いいですね
こんなもう早く死ねるんだから
こんな嫌な体
もうこれで終わりますからね
嫌なことも 嫌な出来事も いろんなことを もうこれで 置いておくんだからね
楽でよかったと
これは言ってはいけません
それは
仏教の世界でも そんなことは言いません
でも一応 理解するために
そんな感じで 死も見なくちゃいけない
決して 暗いものではないんだ
当たり前のことなんです
その目で 我々は ターミナルケアであろうが
末期的な病気にかかっている人々の面倒を見る時も
その心なんです
必要なのは
その心でやるならば
私は 何の説教をする必要もないんです
これ ごく普通
常識　当たり前のことで
それは社会問題ではありません
ニュースに出るぐらいのことじゃないんですよ
国会で延々と 議論するものじゃないんです
なんで今 それを延々と議論するんですかね
当たり前のごく普通のことだから
そんなものはもう 国会なんか始めた時も決めた方が良かったのに
1946年で
決めといた方が良かったのに
だって普通のことでしょう
人が年取って もう寝たきりになったりして
後で死んじゃいますよと
治らない病気はあるんだよ ということは
今更 発見したんですかね
やっぱり末期がんになったらどうしようかと よく考えること
末期がんみたいな もう治らない病気っていうのは
今 最近の出来事だったらニュースなんですけど
それだったら国会でも議論するわ
いろんなところで議論するということはいいんだけど
いかに人間は事実から離れて 非科学的かというなんですね
新しく 21世紀で
人間の大変 大問題
老化問題とか 何 おっしゃってますかと
そんなことは 人類が現れて以来あることで
だから仏教の見方っていうのは
その目で見る
まず 当たり前だと
何のこともないんだと
そんなことに準備してないんだったら
バカもいいところだと
我々はこの玄関に鍵かけるの忘れちゃったら ものすごく怒られるでしょ
あんたもう なんでそんなにボケてるんですか？
とか　ちゃんと気をつけて玄関に鍵でもかけなさい
でも別に 玄関に鍵かけなかったからって言って 泥棒入るわけないでしょうに
で そういうことは当たり前だと言ったりする
私は別にあんまり当たり前だと思っちゃわないんですね
鍵かけ忘れちゃったら
あっ 鍵かけ忘れちゃったなと思うだけ
それで部屋に入ってみたら
あ 泥棒も入ってないんだと
だから別にどうってことはなかったと
鍵かけ忘れて 家に入ったら 泥棒入ってたら
なるほど
鍵をかけ忘れたんだから 泥棒入ったんだと
当たり前だと思っちゃうんです
そうすると 心の落ち着きは ずっとあるでしょうに
それで人が末期状態になったら
このターミナルの その間では
我々は その人の面倒を見なくちゃいけない
本人には 自分のことを見ることできませんからね
その時は ごく普通に 元気な時もお茶入れてあげたし
ご飯も作ってあげたし
そんな気持ちで
じゃあご飯食べますか
今日はとかね
そんな感じで見れば すごい楽なんです
自分は大体 この人がなかなか あまり経験はないんだけど
あの 何人かね
病気になって 面倒を見なくちゃいけないことになった時は
あまりにも当たり前でやっていたんですね
じゃあ どうします？
ご飯なんですけど
ご飯食べる？
とか　薬なんですけど
ご飯 食べる前に
30分前に薬 飲まなくちゃいけないんですけど
だから ごく普通な顔で
そうしながら 私は私の人生で遊んだり
いろんなことをやったりする
そこで お世話してもらう人にとっては
もう想像を絶する リラックスするんですよ
何もわがままに ああ
ご飯ですか
じゃあ 食べますとかね
言って 自分で食べられないんだったら食べさせてあげたりするだけで
ああ 大変だとかね
一言も言わないんです
ああ びっくりしましたとかね
で 私は出家された大長老がもう
3ヶ月間くらい病気で いろいろ治療していたんだけどね
で もっと体力もあった
年上のお坊さんたちがいたんだけど
薬 飲まないんですよ
あげると
みんな あまりにも偉い長老だから 何か言いたくても言えないんです
怖くて
そこで
トラブル起こったりするし
長老ももう みんなに叱ったりもするし
で 長老に怒られるのは みんなすごい怖がってるし
それで私は一応 面倒を見ることに
自分勝手に もう勝手に始めたんですね
他の人々は いろんな薬を作ってくる
私はチェックして
3時の薬だ
6時の薬とか見てて
先生のところに 先生
3時の薬ですけど
あ そう
じゃあ ちょっと起こしてくれ
それだけ
で 私は起こしてあげる
それで もう薬を取って
すごくもう 私に対しても愛情いっぱい
それで私からも すごい愛情が生まれてくるんですね
もうなんの文句も言わないで
このすごい偉大なる人物が 何のことに
あ そうじゃ
起こしてくれ
で 起こしてあげる
それで薬を取って飲む
で 口を洗う
口を洗うんだから
水というと
ちゃんと手のところに水がある
水を飲んで口も洗って
また横にしてあげる
で その間に何かあったら 何かしてあげるんだけど
またはどこかに走っていって
何か もう若い頃でしたからね
いろいろ みんなをからかったり遊んだりも
それもしている
それも長老にも聞こえるし
外 行って遊ぶ時間がなかったら
その前で 他の同じ年の人と喧嘩したり
いろいろなことをやり合ったりもする
全然 怒りも何もしない
あんまりにも当たり前でやってるんだから
で 一回 私はなんかできなくて
何か他のことをやっていて 手が空かなかったんですね
そこで 私の上の長老が 薬を作って持って行ったんですね
持って行ったんだけど
大長老から いろんな質問されるわ
されるわ
なかなか大変なんですね
これは6時の薬ですか？
はい
そうでございますけど
じゃあ ちょっと調べてみなさいと言って
また調べてると たくさん薬のリストあったんだから
どちらどちら それで不安になっちゃうんですね
薬 間違ってるんではないかと
ね あんたね
これ ちゃんと調べて 確認してから持ってくるものではなく
それで言われるんですよ
で 確認していないということは
本当は確認しているんですね
作る時は
で この長老も ちゃんと確認して 持ってきているのに
わがままを言わないで 飲んでくれという気持ちなんですよ
なんで そんなに今
その時 その長老ももう
60歳でしたと思いますけど
お世話した長老もこんな年になって
いまだに私にいろんなわがままを言う という気持ち 大人だから
で 薬 飲まなかったんで
そこで
私の仕事は
私はものすごく走って
子供でしたからね
もう何のことなく
ガタガタと走って 部屋に行ったところで
長老もお手上げ状態で
薬は飲まないし
私はなんでしょうかね
じゃあ
この私に言ったら
なんか長老の薬ですけど
あ そう
じゃあ 私持ち上げますと言って
私は 先生
これは3時の薬ですけど
ああ そう
じゃあ 何のことない
じゃあ 起こしてくれと
すぐ問題が解決しました
だから亡くなる瞬間までも
私といろんな話をしながら
いろいろ話
もういろんな
もう何て言いますか
死ぬ時はいろんなね
もう幻覚みたいなものが見えたりするでしょうしね
それを言ったりする
私は知ってるんだから
他の人々は もうわからないんだから
変なことを言う
長老の気に入らないんで
そうすると　いろんな幻覚
たまたま見えても
ちゃんと知識あって
ちゃんとしている人だから
私は何のことなくそれに付き合う
ああ そうですか
一回 言ったのは
この上に 何か乗せているんではないかと
その時 病院の上に 何か乗せているんではないかと
これ 倒れてきたら大変だよと
何か見えてるんですよ
私は ああ
そうね ああ
これ大丈夫です
これは落ちませんね
で言ったら
ああ そう
ああ そうですか
それで落ち着く
ただそれだけ
また一回
なんで自転車 こちらに置いてるんですかね
これ落ちるかもしれませんよ
何か見せて言うんですね
そしたら え？
え？これ落ちませんよ
先生 これは落ちません
ちゃんと入れてますと
で ベッドから動けないんですけど
ずっと 24時間
私は一人
ずっと面倒を見るために 待っていたんです
で いきなりもう外へ行きたいと
で これ 2日間
その喧嘩あったんだけど
まあ交代もしますから
他の長老たちは この問題をむちゃくちゃにしちゃって
で 外へ行ってと言っても
行けませんよと
もうベッドにいなくちゃいけませんよとか言われて
これ認めない 長老が　とにかく外へ行きたいんだと
で 私がベッドのそばへ行ったら
ちょっと外へ行きたいんだけど
だから私は　あー
でも雨が降ってますよ
何のことなく　なんとなくなんかパラパラと雨が降ってますよと
あ そう
じゃあ風邪引いちゃいますからね
風邪引いちゃいますからね
だから この亡くなるその時までそうやって
ごく普通に
もう当たり前で
もう何のことなく面倒を見て
かなりもう楽でした
私はほとんど
3ヶ月近く もう寝たことは覚えてないんだけど
それで最終的には
1週間ずっともう
1分も寝ることができなかったんだけど
全然 もう体 疲れたわけでも何でもなく
楽しかったんですよ
だから亡くなる時も いきなり心臓発作が出てきて
私の手を握ったんだけど
なんでこんなに力あるんですか？
私はものすごい 信じられなかったんですね
こんなに年取っているのに
その瞬間で
もしかすると そんなに力あるんだったら
やっぱり元気になるかもしれませんという 余計な希望も出たんだけど
やっぱり元気になったどころじゃなくて
そのまま 息を止めちゃったんですね
息を止めた瞬間で
私は あ 私の仕事も終わったと
その瞬間 私の仕事が終わったと
それで行って
隣のお寺に行って
いっぱいご飯を食べて 寝ちゃったんです
仕事 終わったと
すごい悲しかったんだけど
それはもう 後でゆっくりと
やっぱり長老が亡くなったんだって 思い出すと悲しかったんですけど
正直なところ
だからこの ターミナルケアっていうのは ごく普通
当たり前のことだから
当たり前のことで見なくちゃいけない
当たり前のことだと見たら
もう何も言うことはなく
ものすごい簡単にできるんですね
例えば もう寝たきりの人がもう同じように
歩きたいと言ったならばね
じゃあ歩いてみる？
と言ってみれば どうですかね
いちいち おせっかいしないで
じゃあ歩いてみる？
私は手を出しませんよ
それぐらいのことで
なんとか うまくいくんです
それから一番 問題になるのは
例えば がんとかになって
すごい頭がしっかりしている
歩ける で
健康的な人々
末期状態なんですけど
他の問題はない
ホスピスなんかのところにいる人々の場合はね
で 喋られる
話すこともできる
新聞も読める
テレビも見られる
そこら辺 散歩もできる
その人々の場合は
体のことは別に
そういう状態だから 自由でしょうし
その人々とは いろんなことをしゃべり
しゃべったらいいんですね
何をしゃべるかというと
そのポイント大事なんですよ
例えば 我々はしゃべりたがる
希望するのは
もしかするとね
もう超能力でも 神様の力でもあって
病気治ったらありがたいですよとかね
そういうSF的な話はしたがる
考えたがるんですけど
そうではなくて
いつでも 事実をしゃべるんですね
例えば そういう人がね
もう私が死ぬんだからね
財産のことは 会社なんですけどね
子供たちには ちゃんとやれるかどうか
ちょっと わからないんだとかね
そんなくだらんことを考えてもね
意味がないでしょうと
どうせ死ぬ時はね
そんなものを置いておくんだから
後から何やるかと 誰にも管理できないでしょうに
そんなものが潰れたっても
どうってことないでしょうにと
子供たちが もし会社を倒産させたら
それはそちらの問題でしょうにと
あんた それ持っていくつもりですか？
そうやって ちょっと 失礼そうに聞こえる 事実を語ればいいんです
ある長老が 突然
熱を出して 病気になって
いきなり 体が震え始めて 怖くなったんだよ
その人が
で もしかすると 死ぬかもしれませんと
今まで 死ぬっていうことは 考えたことなかったんですね
だから 用意しなくちゃいけないことが いっぱいあるんですね
死ぬ前にという
で お寺のことはどうしますか？
もう弟子たくさんいたんだから
その人はどうしますか？
あの人はどうしますか？
とかね いきなり お寺の鍵のところから始めて
お寺の権利証のところで いきなり始めて 喋り出しちゃったんですね
それで我々は 電話かけて医者に来てくださいと言っているところでしたけど
医者が来るまで 待たなくちゃいけない
なんかもう あまりにも大騒ぎで
しゃべるは しゃべるは
もう大変で
その長老の弟子たちが 周りにいたんだけど
私は その日は用事があって そのお寺に行っただけなんですけど
私よく知ってる長老で あまりにも大騒ぎすると
私は すぐ分かったのは
本人が もしかすると この病気で死ぬんだということを考えているんだと
だから混乱している
いきなり言ったのは
先生 持っていくつもりですかね
それ と
この権利証と鍵をね
怒鳴ったんです
持っていくんですかね
そんなもの
いきなり怒鳴っちゃったら
さっと全部 消えちゃって
全部 消えちゃって
おとなしく座って
お医者さんが来るまで待とう
で それだけ
私はすごい年上でしたから
そんなこと言えたんだけど
周りにいる弟子たちは 本当にみんな子供で 若者で
20代ぐらいでね
もうあまり何も言えなかったんですね
この 80歳の長老に
で その時も かなりこの頭
記憶力がなくなっちゃっていたし
私は昔 かなり体が大きかったんです
そこで もう後ですごく痩せちゃってたし
だから 私のことが わからないんですね
わからないんだけど
どこかで声を覚えているんです
もうかなりしつこいこと
きついことを言うんだったよ
で すごいきついことを言われた途端
何のことなく 受け入れちゃって
そうでないと 病院に連れて行ったんだけど
看護婦さんにも面倒くさいし
医者にも面倒くさい
何を言うか きりがないんだから
だから 事実を言って 脅した方がいいんです
おだてるんじゃなくて
慰めるんじゃなくて
時々 例えば すごく仕事をして 大財産作った人だったら
それを言い始めるんですよ
私はこういう風に仕事をして
こんな風に苦労して
1日1食しか食べないで
それも おにぎり
1個しか食べないで
もうこういう仕事を始めたんだと
それから こういうことをして
戦争の時は こんな苦労してとかね
やっと このところまで持ってきたんだとかね
だから死ねないんですよ
このものに執着あるんだから
その場合は はっきり言った方がいいんですね
そこまで苦労して作ったってのは 結局 無意味ですね
そんなものは 捨てなくちゃいけないんだから
全部 捨てなくちゃいけないんだから
無意味ですねとか 言った方がいいんです
それで 不思議に 心が落ち着くんです
だから 何を教えるべきかというと
やっぱり
そうやって みんな置いていくんだ
みんな旅人だ
短い時間しかいないんだと
そう言われると笑えるんですよ
例えば 自分の息子が ずっと喧嘩ばっかりして
もう勘当されている
勘当されている息子でも
やっぱり お見舞いに来たりする
我が強い人が その時でもあの調子でしょ
でも その時はもう
みんなもう全部 捨てていくんだ
旅人でしょうと
こんなわずかな
わずかにこの中で みんないることだけですよ とか言われたら
勘当してた
自分の息子来たって
まあ 君 元気？
とかなんとか一言 言える
それで向こうも大変 喜ぶでしょうに
勘当されている人も
すごく向こうが喜んだったら
こちらも喜ぶでしょうに
ああ よかったと
仲直りできて とかということになるんです
そうすると また喜びが出てくる
それで 喜びの心で死ねるんですね
ですから
ターミナルケアっていうのは 当たり前の事実として 何の不思議もない
そういう目で見なくちゃいけない
次に言いたいポイントは
このガンなんかになってきたら
すごく体がもうおかしくなったり
一番 我慢できないのは
例えば 吐いたりすることっていうのは
吐けば それで問題解決するでしょ
この 体の痛みなんですよ
いろんなところに痛みが出てくると
ご飯 食べられないといえば
現代的には もう問題ないし
点滴で栄養をあげればいいしね
そういうのは あまり本人も問題にはしません
でも 痛みなんか いろんなものが出てきたりしちゃうと
気持ち悪くなったりするとね
で どうしようもない
その時また 気が落ちる可能性はあります
気が弱くなる可能性はあります
その時は
痛みそのものを 観察させちゃうんですね
瞑想したことがない人だったら
誘導的に観察させればね
どこら辺が痛いですか？
どこからどこまで 痛いんですかと
どのように痛いんですか？
それについて 延々と質問する
そうすると
その人がどうしようもなく
自分の痛みというものを 見るようになるんですよ
で 一言
また決まり言葉を言うんですね
体っていうのはそういうものだと
そんなものはね
やっぱり 捨てた方がいいと思うのは正しいんだ
生まれたときからも 体というのは痛みだけですよと
今 ただそれは 集中的に攻撃しているだけですと
ですから 全部 捨てた方が楽だよと
ということを言ってあげると
体は自分のものでない と思いなさいと
で 気持ちは楽になります
楽な気持ちで死ねます
で どうしても仏教でいうのは
悔しい心で死ぬことは 不幸だと
いやいやで死ぬのは 不幸だと
死にたくない
死にたくないと思って死ぬことほど 不幸なことはないんだと
死ぬんだよ という気持ちで死ななくちゃいけない
だから それ観察しているんだったら
死ぬ時は 面白くなるんですよ
例えば 死ぬことをずっと瞑想した人だったら
あ なるほど
今まで考えていた あの待ちに待っていた
死ぬ時は こういうことか
死ぬ時はこうなるんだ
ああ いろいろ幻覚も見えるんだとかね
それで面白がるだけ
なんかSF映画を見ているような感じで
だから 用意して死ぬ
死にかけている人が用意していないと
用意してあげる
だから ポイントは 落ち着いていること
当たり前の事実だと 看病する人もされる側も認めること
常に 面白く問題を見る
病気になったら
病気ってこんなもんかなとかね
これ とんでもないものだ
例えば 心臓発作ね
とんでもないことですね
この心臓発作っていうのは
だから 心臓発作はすごい
この我慢できない
忍耐できない痛みでしょうね
どれぐらい強烈かというと
心臓発作というのは2回
受けちゃうと もう逝っちゃいますからね
それぐらい痛いもんなんですよ
がんの痛みっていうのは それほどではないんですね
じわじわと ゆっくりと時間をかけて 痛みが起こる
心臓発作は 全部まとめていっぺんに瞬時に来る
で そういうことだから
うーん
体をね　何でしたっけ？
アナータピンディカという お釈迦様の在家の弟子がいて
お釈迦様に対して随分 40年か じゃない
30年間かな ずっと
お釈迦様の面倒を見てあげた人で
巨大なお寺を作って 寄付をして
毎日 お坊さんたちに会っている
お坊さんたちのところがもう お釈迦様がその人のお寺に泊まっていると
毎日 会って話したりしている
お釈迦様のことを心配して お釈迦様に質問はしない
みんな質問するんだから
私まで行って質問して 迷惑をかけてはいけないんだと
それを知っているお釈迦様はね
こいつはバカだから 質問ぐらいすればいいんではないかということだから
来たら 何か教えてあげる
それで その人は 死にかけちゃったんですね
病気になって
で 末期状態 治らない
で お釈迦様は行かなかったんですね
それでも で
自分の一番弟子であるね
サーリプッタ尊者よ
あんた ちょっと様子を見なさいよと
お釈迦様は心配していない
当たり前なんですね
まあ どうせその人は 苦しく死ぬわけじゃないし
お釈迦様は長い付き合いだから
それでも様子を見てこいと言ったら
サーリプッタ尊者が行って
お釈迦様もやっぱり お見舞いに来るようにと言われたんだ と言って
どうですかね
体の調子はと
何か 痛みは楽になってくるんですか？
と聞いたんです
そしたら 楽になるどころじゃない
私の頭は 皮のロープ
そういうもので
力強い人々が皮を巻いて 両側で引っ張ってるような感じで
こちらへんは痛いんだと
お腹の方は 鋭い刃物で刺しているように
胸の方がね
すごく痛みがあるんだと
それ どんどん強くなってくるんだと
そうしたら サーリプッタ尊者っていうのはね
やっぱり
目は私のものだと思ってもね
結局 目から苦しみが生まれてくるだけで
ですから
これ 私のものじゃないと 捨てた方がいいやと
耳は私のものだと思っているんだけど
耳からいろんな苦しみが生まれるんだと
それも捨てるんだと
体も私のものだと思っているんだけど
こんな苦しみが生まれてくるんだから
それ全部 捨てるんだと
それで 考え方
私の考え方 と思っているんだから
苦しみが生まれてくる
それも捨てるんだと
すべて捨てるんだよ
すべて捨てて
捨てて
何もないんだ
という風な話を ずっと言ったんですね
言ったら楽になったんですよ
これ 私の体と思ったところで 嫌になっちゃう
捨てますよと 体 と思って
ものすごい楽になって 驚いちゃって
心は感動すると 痛みが感じなくなっちゃうんですね
感動して驚いちゃって
なんていうお経ですかと
今まで一度も そんな話は聞いたことがないんだと
そしたら そんな話はね
在家のあなた方にわからないんだから 言わなかったんだよ
今まで　理解しないんだから
と言ったら　そんなこと言わないで
これは先におっしゃってくれた方が良かったんではないかと
私は本当に楽になりましたと
すべて捨てるべきですよ
と言って
喜びで
ものすごい喜びを感じ始めたんです
痛みはもう 飛んでいっちゃったんです
なんていう喜悦感か 喜び感かと
思った時
サーリプッタ尊者
これでいいや
もう死ねるんだ
この人はと言って 出てきたんです
じゃあ 帰りますと
だから苦しみで もう我慢できなくなった人には
瞬間に最高の喜びを作ってあげたんです
で じゃあ帰ります
言ったら もう帰って
その場で もうあの方が亡くなっちゃったんです
でも 戻って遺体を見ようということじゃなくて
サーリプッタ尊者 そのままお寺に帰っちゃったんです
で 帰って 彼がもう天国に生まれ変わったんだと言ってますから
サーリプッタ尊者がお寺に行くと （アナータピンディカは）天国に生まれ変わって
神様になって お釈迦様に挨拶したんだと
そしたら お釈迦様に（サーリプッタ尊者が）報告すると
もうあの在家の信者さんが 大変 喜びを感じて
最後に息を止めたんだと
私はそのまま帰りましたと
ああ そう
私も知ってますよ
もう挨拶に来ましたからと
お釈迦様も答えたんだそうですね
だから お釈迦様にサーリプッタ尊者が会う前に
お釈迦様は 死んだ人とはもう喋ってるんです
ですから
決まりは 小さい時 楽しく生きていたんだから
後で 欲ばっかし作って わがままで苦しんでるだけで
そこを抑えれば 生きることも楽しく生きていられる
死ぬ瞬間でも すごいニコニコと楽しく死ねるようにと してあげなくちゃいけない
ターミナルケアする場合は
本当に得するのは ケアする人々なんですよ
大体 みんな損していると 勘違いしているんですよ
寝たきりの人がいると
自分が損しているんだと
逆なんです
ずっと面倒見なくちゃいけない人が もう死にかけている人がいるということで
面倒を見る人も 得しているんですよ
ものすごい
もう想像を絶する得しているんです
なぜかというと 事実を見られる
自分も真理に目覚める
死は当たり前のことだと 自分で体験できる
生きることは なんと苦しいことかとわかる
私もあの大長老がね
最後の時は体が痛くて
いろんな痛みがあって
いかに苦しんでいたかと 見ていたんだから
すごい自由な方が 自由が全部なくなったところで もうかなりストレスでしょうに
そこで息を止めた瞬間で
あの体と一緒に あの苦しみが全部なくなるでしょう
だからどこかで
あ よかったという気持ち
こちらも生まれてくるんですね
苦しまないでよかったと
それはまあ
仏教の人々ですからね
別に死後のこともあまり心配しないし
ちゃんと みんな用意しているし
それはいいんですけど
用意してない人の場合はね
本当にかわいそうですけどね
だから死の準備は 生まれて間もない時からやってください というのは我々の言い方なんです
それだけ後回しにして
あんた がんで死に行ったところで
驚くのはよくないんですね
で 告知してもらわなくてはいけないんですよ
末期病気だったら 告知してもらって
で 残りの短い１日は １日じゃなくて
日にちはどのようにするかと
残っている
2ヶ月間も
まだ我が強くて
もう欲張って 頑張って 金儲かることに励むか
そんなものはバカバカらしいやと思って落ち着いているか
本人決めればよろしいしね
ですから
告知することは すごく必要なことなんです
ショックを受けちゃったら 頭が悪いということで
そこら辺 直してあげなくてはいけないんですね
で どうしようもないのは
このボケちゃって
何もわからなくなっちゃってね
コミュニケーション 何も取れない場合は
どうすることもできませんね
だから若いうち
脳細胞を死なないように
ボケないように ちゃんと瞑想でもしておいた方がいいんです
なぜかというと
完璧にボケて
何ももうわからん
何もわからなくなっちゃって
耳も聞こえなくなっちゃって
死にかけて
2 3週間ね
機械の中にいても
生きてる人々にも 何の手助けもできなくなっちゃう
だから汚れた心で死んでしまう
それは前もって 気をつけた方がいいんですね
智慧だけは 脳細胞が元気な時は作っておくんだということ
大体 これぐらいの内容で 十分だなと思います
とにかく すべての問題は どこから生まれてくるかというと
死ぬのは嫌という その一言から出てきます
それは嘘だとわかってるんだけど
心が認めたくない
だから 死にませんということで生きてます
ですから
今日の話は 全部そのポイントだけなんです
死の瞑想も
その心を直すための 一つのプログラムなんです
そういうわけで
初期仏教では それほど天国の話と 永遠な命とは言わない
必要ではない
それはもう一つの 慰めというか
ごまかしになってしまう
こう言ってもいいんです
あんたは 正しく立派な人間で生きていたならば
死後もそれなりの結果を得るでしょうと
あんたは良い人間で生活していたんだから
地獄に落ちるんだよというのは ありえない話でしょうに
それはありえない話ですから
だから人にはね
あんたこういうすごくいいことをしていたんだからね
いいんじゃないか
今はね というふうに励ますことはできます
もしいいことを一つもしたしたことがない人だったら
あんたね
よくも今まで 何もいいことを一つもしてこなかったと
あんた死ねませんよと
死んじゃったら とんでもないことになるんだと
まず脅す
とんでもないことになるんだと
だからもう早く頑張れと
心っていうのはすぐ変わるもんだから
1時間さえあればいいんだと
心直すために
ちょっと 1時間あればいいんだと言って
このすごい 死に対する恐怖感は とことん作ってあげなくちゃいけないんです
何もいいことをしないで
悪いことばっかりして
あるいは犯罪までして
それで死にかけちゃうと
もう ものすごくおかしくなる
それで本人もおかしくなってるんだから
とことん脅して
この極致のところまで
脅しちゃうんですよ
もうすごく
そうすると もう行き詰まりですよ
恐怖感の
じゃあ あんたどうしますか？
と それでやっと心が変わるんです
だから いいことをした人だったら
褒めてあげる
慰めてあげればいいんですよ
問題ないんですね
あるいは
残り時間も もう慈しみの瞑想でもしましょうと言ったら
何のことなくしてくれる
問題ないんです
悪人はどうしますかというと
やってくれませんから
わからないんだから
そんな話は
だから悪人の場合は 恐怖感のもう極端なところまで脅しちゃうんです
いくら泣いても もう気にしないで
だって当たり前ですよ
あんた一つもろくないいことをしたことがないで
親は裏切ったし
親は悩ませたし
先生も悩ませたらしい
泥棒もしたりしましたし
その上 人まで殺したしと
よくもやったもんだなと
考えてみれば 一かけらもいいことないでしょうに
だからその結果
全部 もうすぐ得られますよと
人間騙しちゃっても 自分の心は騙せませんと
もう そろそろ
もうすぐ あなたは適当な結果を得られますよと
というと
自分も 自分が死ぬんだということを知っているんだから
もうすぐ そろそろですよと
地獄に落ちるの
だから この究極的な
これ以上は恐怖感を感じないというところまで 心が悩んじゃうんですよ
その瞬間で
じゃあ あんたどうしますか？
と そこで教えてあげる
心を直すっていうことは いとも簡単にできますよと
ちょっと1時間30分ぐらいやればできますよと
じゃあ これからすべての生命に申し訳ないんだと
すべての生命が幸せでありますようにと
こんなような私も ここまでみんなのおかげで生きてきたんだよと
というふうに 慈しみの気持ちを作ってあげる
それで悪人でも地獄には落ちません
死ぬ時は喜びで
本当に 慈しみを感じながら死んじゃったら 地獄に落ちません
それで それは仏教の 死ぬ人々に対する見方なんですね
それでストーリーがありまして
お釈迦様
これは もう話はほとんど終了しています
今一応